c'est non non
[Musique]
les deux tiers de l'humanité meurent de
faim au moment même où je vous parle
dans le monde entier des millions
d'enfants famélique
ce fan doucement avant même d'avoir vécu
pendant ce temps que fait l'homme
occidental est bien l'homme occidental
ce gaz de viandes grasses et il se
boursoufle de saindoux et c'est
dégoûtant allons nous supporter plus
longtemps je dis non c'est pourquoi dès
maintenant nous allons tous ensemble
observé une minute sans dodaine pour
tous les enfants affamés du monde entier
alors si vous le voulez bien à mon
commandement 1 2 3 etonnant non
[Musique]
fait étonnant non